mr speaker we cannot stand up to russian
aggression abroad while accepting
russian corruption at home
for too long britain has been the
destination for the dirty money that
keeps putin in power
so where is the economic crime bill
promised by the government and then
pulled
where is the comprehensive reform of
companies house
where is the law to register foreign
agents where is the register of overseas
entities bill
where is the replacement for the
outdated computer misuse act where are
the new rules on political donations
why does the government's elections bill
make these problems worse
by enabling political donations from
donors based overseas
whether or not president putin invades
ukraine
russia's long-run pattern of aggression
demands a nato response
so can the secretary of state report
from his meeting last week with nato
defense ministers on how the alliance's
overall posture is set to change
can he explain what could be taken
to better coordinate nato with the joint
expeditionary force for instance
creating a regional readiness force
and finally
does ukraine not expose the flaws in the
government's integrated review last year
with its first focus on the indo-pacific
and with its plan to cut the british
army by another 10 000 soldiers
will he now halt any further army cuts
and will he restore the highest defense
priority to europe the north atlantic
and the arctic
[Music]
uh i was security minister mr speaker
when i introduced the criminal's finance
act i there was no more greater champion
on taking down dirty money in the city
than me i brought in the unexplained
wealth orders i brought in the mobile
stores of wealth where people got around
it and in fact helped set up the
national uh within the national crime
agency the economic crime unit i also
made sure that we changed the law around
uh tax evasion to make sure we got more
people and pushed incredibly hard and
successfully and through the i think it
was the g7 uh the transplant register of
beneficial ownership he's absolutely
right we need to do more i absolutely
supported at the time and still do a
registered foreign agent
and i am
the whole of government is now looking
at those issues and i think he is
totally right around areas like
companies house the government is
committed to do something about it uh i
expect an announcement soon on a range
of those issues but he's right that the
consequences of russia action going way
back to salisbury before is that we must
stop the oligarchs and their dirty money
a resident in this country behaving
as a as a place of refuge when in fact
they should not be welcome and if it
comes to an invasion of ukraine russia
should know what it costs to be isolated